Hallo, meine Lieben. Willkommen
zu einem neuen Video von mir.
Ihr habt mir
auf Instagram geschrieben,
dass ihr mal wieder gerne
einen Labor Haul hättet.
Euer Wunsch ist mir Befehl.
Es geht hier nie um "product
placements" oder "affiliate links",
sondern einzig und allein um euch.
Meine Community, meine Familie,
ich liebe euch.
Deswegen zeige ich euch nun
viele Produkte, die ihr kaufen könnt.
Wer kennt das nicht?
Jeden Tag ist man im Labor,
man hat dasselbe an,
nämlich einen weißen Kittel
und eine Schutzbrille.
Nur weil wir Kittel
und Brille tragen,
heißt es noch lange nicht,
dass wir langweilig aussehen müssen.
Wir alle kennen unsere guten alten...
Ups!
Die Handschuhe sind runtergefallen.
Lasse ich drin,
das wirkt menschlich.
Ich meine, blaue Handschuhe
passen echt gut zum weißen Kittel.
Ja, ich verstehe, dass das
die am meisten verkaufte Farbe ist.
Aber ganz ehrlich, Leute,
langsam wird es etwas langweilig.
Der Herbst 2017
steht im Namen von knalligen Farben.
Passt auf. Haltet euch fest.
Ist das nicht toll?
So sonnig!
Schaut euch an,
wie das mit dem Kittel aussieht.
Wenn ihr denkt,
dass das schon cool war:
Hier kommen meine absoluten
Lieblingshandschuhe. Leute!
Manche Labore haben
diese lila Handschuhe,
die sind eine nette Abwechslung.
Aber ganz ehrlich,
nichts geht über Pink.
Natürlich sind
all diese Handschuhe aus Nitril.
D.h., sie lassen Aceton durch,
damit euer Nagellack auch immer schön
zerstört wird, wie es sich gehört.
Wenn ihr jetzt doch mal mit
größeren Mengen an Säure arbeitet,
oder besseren Schutz
von Lösungsmitteln braucht,
habe ich, Leute...
Ist es nicht schön?
Rot ist nicht ganz so meine Farbe,
das muss ich sagen.
Aber ich dachte,
die sind trotzdem nett,
weil die so viel von dem
weißen Kittel dann auch verdecken
und etwas mehr Farbe
ins Labor bringen.
Es sind nicht
die praktischsten Handschuhe.
Also feinmotorische Arbeiten
sind nicht ganz so einfach.
Aber was tut man nicht alles
für den richtigen Look?
Machen wir weiter mit Eyewear.
Das ist die Brille,
die ich schon länger benutze.
Das Problem ist, wie ihr
vielleicht schon gemerkt habt,
ich habe keine Nase.
Da ist eine leichte Erhöhung
mit zwei Atemlöchern drin,
aber eine richtige Nase
ist das nicht.
Deswegen habe ich das Problem,
dass ich alle 2 Minuten
den hier machen muss.
Wenn ihr auch eine zarte Nase habt,
habe ich etwas ganz Tolles für euch.
Und zwar: Diese Schutzbrille
ist mit einem Gummiband versehen.
Und so kann nichts mehr verrutschen.
Aber ihr kennt mich,
ich mag es gerne etwas extravaganter.
Deswegen, Leute,
schaut euch diese Schönheit an.
Das ist natürlich auch
ein ganz toller Schutz
für ein "full face of make up".
Ich kann euch kurz zeigen,
wie das in Kombination
mit den gelben Handschuhen aussieht.
Nämlich "flawless".
Wenn ihr mal so einen Tag ab,
wo ihr denkt, "being myself",
könnt ihr natürlich auch
"all out" gehen
und diese Kombination rocken.
Alle Links
zu diesen wundervollen Produkten
gibt es
unten in der Videobeschreibung.
Wenn ihr beim Checkout
den Code Schönschlau20 verwendet,
kriegt ihr alles 20% günstiger.
Freunde der Sonne, dass hier sollte
kein "shade" oder "hate" sein
für meine Kollegen
aus Beauty und Lifestyle.
Ist ja alles nur ein Spaß.
Auf diesem Kanal geht nicht
alles mit ernsten Dingen zu.
Was ich damit sagen wollte, ist:
Schönschlau als Wissenskanal könnte
von Werbung nur sehr schlecht leben.
Im Wissensbereich ist nicht so
das große Geld, sage ich mal.
Wie ihr vielleicht wisst, Schönschlau
ist eine winzige Produktion.
Wir sind ein Zweier-Team.
Ich produziere die meisten Videos
bei mir zuhause.
Das macht es
zu einer günstigen Produktion.
Aber neben ganz viel Herzblut
fließen auch sehr viel Zeit
und Arbeit in diesen Kanal.
Wenn diese Zeit und Arbeit
nicht bezahlt werden würden,
könnte ich mir diesen Kanal
als Creator einfach nicht leisten.
Deswegen möchte ich mich hiermit
bei euch allen bedanken
für eure Gebühren.
Denn ernsthaft,
gäbe es Funk nicht,
gäbe es ziemlich
sicher keine Werbepartner,
die diesen Kanal
ermöglichen würden.
Zumindest keine, hinter denen ich
mit gutem Gewissen stehen würde.
Ich kann es ziemlich gut verstehen,
falls ihr die Gebühren doof findet,
aber nichtsdestotrotz möchte ich mich
auch bei euch aufrichtig bedanken,
dass ich seit über einem Jahr
Schönschlau machen darf.
Also, danke für euren Support.
Auch, wenn euch nie
jemand danach gefragt hat.
Peace. Bleibt sicher.
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von Funk (2017)